Professor: para o velhinho.
Professor: para um...
Professor: e vamos estar com a roça dele.
Professor: alguma tecnologia que peguei
Professor: para Libras.
Aluno: que a gente totalmente traduziu pra ali.
Professor: O Felipe, você ficou muito lá.
Aluno: O que é o que é o que é o que é?
Professor: Até a próxima!
Professor: Ele ali também.
Professor: Bele.
Aluno: e não é o que eu gosto, é o que eu gosto, é o que eu gosto.
Professor: A desculpa!
Professor: e eu vou simplificar se for derrubar.
Aluno: Também não funcionaria?
Professor: Esparro!
Professor: Ah!
Aluno: Muito obrigado, pessoal.
Professor: Valeu.
Professor: Tá bom, tá bom, tá bom.
Professor: Use esse imídio para...
Aluno: O que é isso?
Professor: Se não é para o domínio...
Professor: a prisão do poder.
Professor: O buff já foi...
Aluno: O que eu vou fazer?
Professor: E
Professor: 300...
Aluno: e mostra-se a gente em um final.
Professor: Muito bem, tudo bem.
Professor: Não tem.
Aluno: É isso aí, educação, né?
Professor: Abre aí!
Aluno: O que é isso?
Professor: E não é.
Professor: Até a próxima!
Aluno: Quem é o que é o que é o que é o que não...
Professor: Tchau!
Professor: Vamos lá.
Professor: O dia 1...
Professor: Achei de pronto.
Aluno: O que é isso?
Professor: Hum.
Professor: Mas fica diferente.
Aluno: A gente está, então é um resasso.
Professor: Tchau.
Professor: de boi
Professor: Tô sendo...
Aluno: O que você está fazendo?
Professor: não são três.
Aluno: O que é isso?
Aluno: E aí?
Professor: Teu... Teu tio.
Professor: Isso é difícil.
Professor: Ta um vídeo!
Professor: Eu mostrei no...
Professor: Eu quero tirar a foto aí.
Professor: Bem-vindo.
Professor: Tchau, tchau.
Professor: Bye!
Aluno: A gente o tem.
Professor: É, é, é...
Professor: Eu vou ter lhe cheio.
Professor: Alô, gasta o aquel...
Professor: Simbolo.
Aluno: Eu sei o que eu sou, sim.
Professor: doido.
Professor: Não, não, não...
Professor: Vou fazer.
Professor: com algumas...
Aluno: O que é isso?
Professor: e dá a função.
Professor: Tchau, tchau.
Professor: Sim, já pronto.
Professor: Não, primeiro dia.
Professor: Muito obrigado.
Professor: Ei, cada um de vocês...
Professor: Sou os que ouviram todo mundo.
Professor: Manda, manda...
Professor: Bota a foto.
Aluno: O que é isso?
Professor: Obrigado!
Professor: Até o vídeo!
Professor: Tchau, tchau.
Professor: Não ficou feio.
Aluno: Tudo ok?
Professor: Só falta...
Professor: por 30.000.
Professor: Obrigado, até o próximo vídeo.
Professor: Cê tem um beijo.
Professor: Você irá gritar!
Professor: Só lá que tem um burro.
Professor: Não pode falar.
Aluno: É isso aí, tá?